Nina also was think about doing a 30 day
fitness challenge weight loss yoga
weight loss challenge was to get back
because it been eating too much um I got
it under how much meaner so we'll see
we'll film it hey Ben finna eat some too
is liking eight and a half pounds in a
week holy cow she hated it this is the
first weigh-in day see how we're doing
it's in a tier there too you didn't save
me a one that's hungry
okay everybody hello we just got back
from a seven-day cruise to the Caribbean
and we ate alive and slept the line and
probably gained a lot of waiting and so
we're going to go on a 30-day challenge
to lose some weight and see how well we
do and take you guys on the journey with
us I never shown had never tell anyone
go away well now come in are you waiting
so we're going to show you the before
wait and then see how we do after 30
days one 27.7 what do you think about
your results it's really bad what's the
goal 113 okay my turn time for big daddy
I think that's a lot it's liking eight
and a half pounds in a week holy cow
like a 30 day challenge for tomorrow
okay
so first step is I've been 30 grams of
protein within the first 30 minutes of
waking up every day that's something
from Tim faris's for our body so I'm
going to be having some whey protein
scoop with that Plus this is just some
vitamins that Nina makes me take every
day and then this one is a probiotic
pills that my sister who's a scientific
genius doesn't take every day so I'm
going to mix the first four things
together and then have a pill and that's
time spent my day every day for the next
30 days
okay next up is breakfast so normally
Nina makes lentils and I eat that for
breakfast every day but we just got back
from our vacation last night late and
she had enough time to make it and I
don't trust in my ability to make
lentils so I made something else today
I'm having two eggs that were fried up
and die so Medina's cereal this is some
homemade granola that she made put a
yummy and then this is a big thing of
water I try to have at least one or two
of these every day i also have a fitness
goal i try to get steps in every day and
use my Fitbit i try to get 20,000 steps
every day and i usually do that by doing
a run 20 minutes on the spot in the
morning watching youtube videos and then
throw the day i will march on the spot
as i listened to my aunt vibes dance
productivity mix so so far i'm at 2,300
steps i have a long way to go
all right after that run 4579 steps
gotta get 20,000 a day so during the day
while I'm working it's going to be step
step step step step until it hits one
cake okay so lunch salad looks like some
nuts and some peppers on top lunch part
two peanut butter and organic honey
sandwich okay still day one we are going
to do some working out I hired a
personal trainer to come and train us
monday wednesday and friday there's some
strength training and then absolute
you're going to have a talk about food
and see how it goes
first workout in a while come on we're
going to get some nutrition tips from
ace fabulous training yeah he looks
tired so what you're going to see here
is called the bi-weekly adherence start
so what this sheet allows us for you
that's the track every single thing okay
so the general guideline for everybody
is the basis that everybody has to have
protein and everything out and protein
makes you pull up Mulder glass hungry of
the less than Z the slack on this if
you're acting all right so this sheet
will give us for 14 days for 14 days and
if we hit eighty percent then you give
us a new food rule yes and if we don't
hit eighty percent you'll stick on this
with real estate at this foot blue for a
while so I'm 180 grams of protein was
going a day holy cow a lot so so what do
we eat tell us what the tuna eggs lean
pork like steamed fish you writing this
down Lena what am I missing their
chicken okay he's gonna make hard I like
to know I'm gonna she's gonna be how we
gotta go look at the console shop
recording yeah protein is coming okay
we're off to costco because we have to
buy a crap ton of protein
that's only gonna eat today that is a
lot of protein and all that tuna at the
start holy cow 180 grams a day serious
meal plan it's already too late right
now so we're going to just make some
salad with some mystery nut and turkey
breast what's breakfast tomorrow
breakfast tomorrow I'm gonna make some
legs on so I could you tell em
protein shake with lentils and an egg or
two eggs for me 2x for you one extra me
all right dinner on the new meal plan is
mixed greens mixed nuts sliced turkey
with olive oil and apple cider vinegar
all right it's day two I've got my
protein drinks to start off by 180 what
is it hundred 80 grams of protein and
yesterday I hit 20 1107 steps so far so
good for day one next up on the food
train is my Nina smoothie this is green
so it's kale I kind of missed this one
of the things I miss the most I'm being
on the cruise ship and don't have one to
two of these per day it's time for some
lentils with an egg all right about to
sit down throughout my book but it's
time for the quick first part of the
lunch which is tuna and olive oil and
some such okay it's over time and I'm
getting for sausages and some peas and
onions so far i am behind i'm
approaching count the ketchup okay so it
is 940 at night on day two and I'm
behind on my steps and behind on my
protein I need to get the 20,000 so I'm
going to do a run till I hit 20 and I'm
about 20 grams behind on my protein so I
have this salad here it's just turkey
slices some nuts and hopefully I'll hit
everything right of it a day
all right time to start day three a
little bit tired today a little bit sore
I don't know why the workout was two
days ago but anyway where's my cake
usual started a protein shake and
yesterday I did 20,000 291 steps and I
had 191 grams of protein a bit over but
Fox heart and it's hard eating that much
protein so full I didn't eat any carbs
all day except for some lentils and it
was so full of going to bed anyway day 3
starts now and I gotta do my morning run
all right I had my breakfast I had 6800
steps pretty good I didn't have my
breakfast I just had the protein shake
now it's time for breakfast I'm going to
be having one of nina's amazing
smoothies looks like it scale based and
again lentils with an egg okay lunch
time filming at EDS getting ready to
film videos for the week and lunch is
solid plus turkey brass wats tuna here
we go alright it's day three work at
time
so it's eleven o'clock we just got home
from bachata night and I realize I
didn't record my dinner because we were
stressed out and rushed in leaving so
mean I made this awesome salad with pork
purpose amazing seasoning I hit 191
yards protein for the day I'm excited
hit my step fool ready to start day for
how did you do I hit blow almost hundred
grand so it's pretty good you said 9200
that's fine how's your stepped off to go
all right get running I'm good for the
day I'll see you tomorrow all right
welcome to day for I realized that that
in my protein shake I'm only having 25
grams of protein to the 30 so that's
knock down my protein totals every day
by five but I'm still over right we've
done in 186 per day instead of 191
yesterday I had 20 2798 steps so
everything is on track looking good
certain day with Nina normal shape
excited for another day time four levels
2 cups of lentils with an egg yummy
yummy so for the workout today I was
going to run but I have to go to throw
in salsa to meet the electrician because
i'm installing some new lights there so
get my winter gear on I'm gonna run
there and run back and get a serious
number of steps alright usual lunch
turkey slices with salad tuna for
another 60 grams of protein so having a
nice Nina smoothie but she didn't drink
today so I get to drink it I'm going to
look at some YouTube comments and answer
while Nina
is what are you making make some wall
dinner I'm gonna make some stir fry with
grumpy then lunch tomorrow who has
salmon salmon salad Barry they're yummy
tired of Turkey and we're out of Turkey
so tomorrow new lunch very exciting
still the same protein yum yum yum Adam
okay you to comment I mean I gave me the
biggest ball I've ever seen in my life I
need to finish tonight are you kidding
me what is this thing like it's bigger
than my laptop this thing I do you know
but that's what you have to eat that's
what I have to eat this is insane yes I
measured it holy kappa what else is holy
cow evan is going to be a eating all
night this is insanity Nina Nina is very
much appreciated and loved and this bowl
look at it is insane oh my so I could
chew third of that cuz one
I don't think like an army of Evans
could finish all this food that's crazy
the bowl is empty into our very full
time for bed snap time it's nap time
with Jesse and now we're going to sleep
good morning and welcome to day 5 I'm
tired I'm tired today got the protein
shake as usual yesterday I did twenty
thousand seven hundred and seventy two
steps so everything's on target today I
have to spend most of the day I've tried
and salsa I'm redoing the lights of
electricians coming in putting in all
new lights and store make sure
everything's going well while I walk
over there bring my lunch and hopefully
can stay on track with everything for
the diet okay time for lunch usual Nina
smoothie this one looks like kale again
and the usual lentils with egg I guess
that's not lunch I guess this is kind of
breakfast I have to shape its kind of
breakfast I'm feeling a little sick
throats hurting bit of a fever hoping I
can still get the TV yes today to do the
electrical stuff because I badly want
those lights in so a little bit more
chill today go get some work done and
eat up ok switch lunchtime and slightly
different lunch today Nina has made some
awesome salmon this looks to me like
it's more than the Porsche I'm supposed
to have she also include a can of tuna
so I need to message her to figure out
whether I need to eat the salmon and the
tuna or just salmon and since I have 60
grams of protein that looks like 60
grams of protein in salmon to me I could
be wrong it might be 30 in which case I
need to have tuna anyway I'm going to
message Nina and then I'm going to be
walking at toronto then salsa to work on
the new lights and I'm going to be
bringing this
with me all right good news is I
confirmed with Nina I don't have to eat
the tuna it's just a salmon so I'm going
to walk the tds get my hat on my hoodie
was my hat gotta get my hat hoodie and
I'm behind on my steps today so gotta
make sure I hit my 20k all right it's a
dinner time yeah it's nothing we have
known it wasn't then we've no dinner
Nina's playing a kicking game on the
ipad I got really hungry tds had to go
get a bar I was looking at I should have
two bars I had to find something wasn't
crazy kind sugar fermented vegan protein
classes what I had taught me I should we
try to the whole foods members before 15
grams of protein so I had 30 grams of
protein ahead 3-2 you didn't save me one
that's hungry do you even meet my goal
for the day 30 30 30 it's only night
it's not enough fortuny I need her 100
you need 40 grams of protein right now
yeah but then no I need 45 how about
having some weight drink that's 25 great
day I don't like those kind of train so
gross I don't know how people could
drink ten oh I think it every day okay
what message do you have for YouTube
nation I'm happy Nina's not just hungry
she's getting angry this is a hangry way
that we got to take care of then the
cameras are whole foods
I've been craving awkward the reasons I
got some
Nina's getting all that looks look at
all that but you get it let's see it
corn mushrooms putting the other one
just the BBQ you happy all right
you're happy because you get to eat we
give me a hard time because you could
need
yeah when Tina's not William is hungry
you don't want to get in the way of that
red kale kale and beat oh no clicks all
right whatever daylin beat it is
okay let's go buy it let's beat the face
there it is
I think I'm feeling peckish so I'm going
to have some popcorn try to the side and
we are playing the game of League of
Legends because the wife wants to
practice for Warwick there we are I'm
hybrid work what's package package means
you wanna is like tekken things like
dirty kind of hungry kind of snack ish
package okay saturday morning quick
update I wait too much pokémon last
night James having fun this is what's
left of the bag I mean even had a little
bit for a little bit yeah most of me
steps were good twenty thousand 152 that
my steps gold is our first Saturday
takes a little chaotic on a Saturday
gonna be a little harder to stay on our
regimented food diet so we'll see how it
goes we're taking a long journey with us
and tomorrow is the first weigh-in day
see how we're doing I like to shirt you
see evony evony is not your daddy mr. of
the day with the shake as usual I'm half
with your mind Nina finish this quickly
she loved it yeah so much she hated it
we're gonna go coffee pop is not really
supposed to be on a diet but it's
Saturday definitely is normally massive
cheat day for us Tim Hortons breakfast
we're having some hash browns and egg
and cheese for Nina Vega Faden egg and
cheese meats forever and of course two
large coffees to milk no sugar for Nina
what to cream one sugar for Evan how
many times quickly heavy an egg is six
right haga six min each I'm gonna say
was 15 8 20 26 1420 I was one with 20
games 50 lunchtime nice time so we
bought this turkey breast from the claws
and on the nutrition facts Pierce says
four slices of turkey breast is 14 grand
a protein I have to eat 16 slices yes to
be 16 slices are there even 16 slices in
there yep there will be 60 so you need
16 slices of the turkey breast oh I oh
no I need to eat eight slices that's a
lot too and I got a scallop it is today
I got asked out a dollar stores I gotta
leave now mr. so gross so we just got
back from car dealership where I had two
cappuccinos which is not great for the
diet in the update I'm at 73 grams of
protein for the day and I need to be a
180 180 by the end the day and it's
already four-thirty so I'm use another
110 almost uh not good not as bad as I
you know Saturday again is usually our
junkie days that be down in frappuccinos
and basically whatever I want hasn't
been super junkie apart from the capital
isn't that bad but not sticking to the
diet as much as I should so hopefully we
have a healthy dinner and we don't fall
too far off track all right it's
dinnertime Nina's made us some broccoli
some what is his pork pork some Oh some
chicken pork some pork Oh cow sound
gravy this here is Hayden he's ready to
eat in his hungry how many grams of
protein are we having tonight I'm 60
shoes work you're playing a game work
game it's called the kingdom rush
something like that young lad I think
that's what it's called 60 grams of
healthy protein ready to eat hey there's
an attempt to write okay Saturday night
it is just past ten o'clock I need only
a thousand more steps I need a thousand
more steps my Fitbit is still on Puerto
Rico time so it it goes to the next day
at 11 instead of into the midnight so I
need to get a thousand steps in 50
minutes which is doable I'm also 25
grams behind on my protein so I'm having
another protein shake maybe have to help
you thing to do at ten o'clock hopefully
I'll sleep but ace and Shawn trying to
make you happy stick to the diet it'll
put me at 188 for the day and my balls
money so we will be good after the
protein shake okay good morning it is
day 7 yes Hayden's here uh Sunday
morning we're up late last night doing
stuff for the car that's awesome
this video on the lights but it looks
really good yeah its way in day its way
in day so I'm just going to go first
name is me go first okay one 23.4 lost
four pounds i started at 20 6.6 i feel
like i was pretty consistent with my
diet just to pop one g 200 point nine
six pounds in a week lots of time of day
it's pretty good that's pretty good I'm
getting happier jus supporting ok well
start a new day new week we should go
celebrate with your cappuccino ok well
another day let's keep tracking weird 7
out of 30 on the way so far so good